[Laughter]
[Music]
all right guys so
on my stories my instagram stories
reposted a video that popped up on my
feet and
it's this video of someone making this
delicious
amazing concoction that just blew my
mind and the first person or the first
two people that i thought of was aunt
christina to do this with
yay thanks for having me
that's so cute you put his hands up too
we're gonna be getting
these strawberries we're gonna carve out
the middle and then we're gonna stuff it
with mango pieces
oh my god my mouth is getting so watery
just talking about it after we do that
the strawberries
are gonna be wrapped in this tamarind
wrap that's actually meant for apples
but
which they gave us you you actually gave
this to us many many many many months
ago
a long time ago i'm not even focusing
right now i just wanna
so we're going to wrap the strawberries
in this we're going to cover the
strawberries with
lime and then once they're all covered
in lime then the final touch is doing oh
no not final touch then we're going to
be spreading it pretty much with the
thyme oh my god i can't speak
and then the final touch is drizzling
chamoy over
it ready for this oh
i don't even know if we're gonna make it
to make the rest of the video because we
might just eat it all and forget
i know that's the hardest part exactly
oh my god okay well
i how do you want to do this because i'm
not very good with knives
and cutting boards but i can try to do
my best what do you want how do you want
to do this hand however you want to do
this is
something that you showed me and i we
could take it step by step we'll start
with the mangoes first and
then the strawberries okay let's do that
mangoes first
oh nice thank you baby i was like your
knife was broken because
it had that classic piece that's all i
saw was like
you're nice and what that reminded me of
with the plastic thing in the knife
first day of being a hitman and then
you're like
accidentally covered
let's take two guys take two all right
so first we gotta wash them
what how do you just peel it with the
peeler oh yeah but i thought like the
way he said it sounded like it was like
some
hack or something to just like crack
open
i don't know i picked oh sorry i
pictured you doing something weird like
this and then just peeling it off i
don't know that would be pretty
that's what i just immediately thought
of so i was like what
everything is automatically weird
that was a burn christina that was a
good burn are you gonna make this
or are you gonna make this oh this
became a hungry ham channel
no i don't know everybody welcome to
hungry and we're today
no i mean that's why i'm like how do you
want to do this end because we want to
do it
oh so when i share this this yes sweetie
what do you need what do you want
you want some more say can i have tahini
girlfriend here we go please say mo
tahin please
thank cutie so when i shared that that
story
with annika
he was eating it yeah i missed it
he was eating that fake plant so when i
shared this with aunt christina
she was like all right we're gonna hang
out we did tacos it was amazing
and then now we're like oh let's try
that video that you shared
he brought over all the ingredients so
that's why i'm like aunt is this a
collab
or what because you you bought these
ingredients
usually the person that does that that
brought the ingredients doesn't need to
make anything
there you go all right
okay baby all right so you get to
chopping buddy
so don't worry about the strawberries
right now is doing the mango
which is going to be tiny tiny little
cubes
that are small enough to stuff the
strawberry wait you're not using the
peeler
okay and so too where's the business
what happened the whole time she's
saying guys no guys no don't put your
face on it don't put your face on and
play it's like licking your mirror oh my
god
she walked by and she was like
i'm so sorry right there
leia now we got leia germs
and enzo germs
[Laughter]
what are you guys doing we get to have
another vlog section
yay
yeah but not when you guys get to upload
in a reasonable time frame and we take
forever to upload it
why is point you guys for that last year
last year
for real man that's how late we are
going to eat the inside of the
strawberry
[Music]
all right so i remembered what's it
called when you do this
following out sure is not holding no
that's what i said oh so look this is my
first one i don't know it might come out
better but i just i can't wait i just
want to know what it looks like
i'm stuffing the strawberry with a mango
oh
look at that
oh my mouth is so watery what else did
we do to that oh and then so we have to
do that next
i'm gonna drench this in lime juice yeah
but no first of all
we could save one mango for just chamoy
mangos
like this size right next to this i
think you were talking about the one on
your thumb
and i was like that's just like milking
what
so i was telling them to just chop them
chop them up bigger so we can just
eat them with sake and lime and
chamomile on their own
because it's gonna be too much mango for
the amount of strawberry and then he was
like
i did this but on the back side all she
was staring at was the little
oh that's how big you want to do them
i'm like that's how big you're doing
oh that looks like a little decoration
that's a really good halloween
[Music]
to get them to write down mexicans wrap
them in newspapers
what yeah so there's even like a like a
disc
or it's like you're so immature you
should wrap yourself in a newspaper
what are you eating there wow
[Music]
when i eat mango seeds i always end up
like you know how like it touches the
corner of your mouth
and maybe i think i'm allergic to
mangoes but it makes my
lips go red and like inflamed and stuff
i'm still salivating and i can't wait
for those to be ready
i want those i can't believe you ate the
whole thing without chamoy
i know not a real mexican by the way
that was so
kind and gracious to say that that
chamoy bottle there is gonna be left in
our
house so i finally owned tamoya a real
mexican
thank you and christina you can do the
honors of popping that cherry
[Music]
did
tiff means business she said take off
her ring that looks fine looks like
you're playing with play-doh now
i want to play this is a real mexican
technique using these uh
this cup it's actually working duh
learn something new every day guys
so how come you're using a glass cup
and a plate instead of a rolling pin
and a cutting board because i didn't
want to make everything all red
very smart but i'm trying to like see if
i can flatten it out some more it's
still way too thick
is that why you took this off you
thought it was going to stain this too
no i just didn't want to get my wrinkles
oh you're just trying to get down to
business
can i see if it fits what if you put
like plastic
oh it's bad luck
because i'm gonna end up marrying casey
no
you don't want to marry me casey we
already had enough bad luck [ __ ] this
got stuck
she has an answer a solution for you oh
saran wrap yeah
yeah yeah yeah the saran wrap on the
panel or you can throw it up like a
pizza
i like that try it go for it
you know what i can just do with my
fingers actually it's flattening out
pretty well
and then we go like this dang it it was
not enough
okay you can piece it together oh it's
supposed to wrap on the top too
frankenstein
it is supposed to cover everything yeah
like uh
okay oh there you go some shape oh no
this is not
this is not happening guys it's not
happening what's wrong salivating
it's pretty good right i'm really really
salivating now
okay frankenstein it does not work so
redo there's a learning process yeah you
can piece it back together probably it's
a learning curve
um that's probably got a lot of flavor
on that strawberry
that is only green and it's only half
done when we put the wrap on
oh true you still gotta do what that guy
right and the tahini and the lime
oh my god goodness this is last it is
it's the drizzle
at the end so it's like quadruple threat
of
sourness that's pretty intense
oh yeah right man i wonder how long it
took the people in
that video to do
well it's working somewhat nice
help me people you're just standing
there and watching me fail miserably
he's watching you we're just critiquing
you here oh this reminds me of making
that don
cause you were saying like this is super
labor intensive where you have to like
get the consistency
of the tamarindo like to a certain like
thinness or thickness whatever you want
to
say it my experience it was making
cotton tots which i had a very
long infatuation with that was the
hardest part getting that outer layer
pastry
to the perfect thickness or thinness
however you want to say it or look at it
and uh this is exactly the same problem
seems like
we got one done though very thick one
too
whoever gets that one's gonna have a lot
of fun so in that video that i saw they
actually use a different
kind of tamarind candy so it's called
parino and that candy is a lot softer
and a lot more malleable i guess
it would be way easier to wrap the
strawberries with
but because we didn't have we did have
that apple
covering thing which is essentially the
same thing but guessing and then the
fact that it's
really old i'm guessing that's why we're
having extra trouble with it
oh ant's doing i'm great professional
roller
king chef yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like a fruit roll-up i just want to
eat that now
freaking
[Music]
i'm like water that uncle that's me it's
not bad whoa
there you go don't show this part
show this part that looks nice yeah you
just lay that down on that split that
side up
cool so we got that
[Music]
yeah what are you guys up to
making desserts we're gonna chill right
here
i like your mickey mouse sweater what
you up to isaac i'm just watching
tick-tock
just watching tick-tock yep your shirt
is sticking
fat your fat belly's sticking out
you think you have a belly then yeah
mine mine's a whole santa claus belly
compared to isaac's
[Music]
what are you up to where you gonna go
where are you gonna go
where are we going we're going on an
adventure with enzo
sister oh yeah
yeah where's the baby where's the baby
there's the baby yeah yeah baby
baby yeah baby yeah
wow
baby baby baby
[Music]
oh
here i'm trying to like figure out how
to make this work
oh my god they're chasing me they're
chasing me
[Music]
oh my gosh there's another one oh no
oh no i get you i know you're gonna give
me two
you got the biggest baby of them all ah
we got
them oh you okay
ah you're gonna get me
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
wow that looks amazing yeah ignore this
ignore the mishaps okay ignore it we
tried really hard
so what's next next is lime so we're
covering these guys oh that's a good
line yeah i was rolling it like crazy so
tip
tip tip tip tip always roll your limes
and your lemons
you get the most juice and oranges even
if it's a dry old one
that will help oh if it's a dry old one
especially put it in the microwave for
like five seconds five ten seconds
and then roll it in it's gonna be good
to go so you heard her
if it's old lumpy brown no it is like
brown
molding after you roll it you throw it
in the trash can
pretty much because it is
oh my goodness this is gonna be like
magic
wow that's happened all over again
what's this what is this thing happening
in my mouth
oh geez do you want me to flip the
strawberries they do the other side
it'll get drenched because it's going
running down and plus there's a whole
nother slice
[Music]
if your mouth isn't watering at home i
don't know what's wrong with you that
was the loudest gulp i've ever heard
casey doody
[Music]
i was going to do two lines but i think
there's one shot
yeah and then man what's next hopefully
it doesn't pull apart because a lot of
these are not very stable
is your mouth watering yet leah i think
so she
did oh yeah wow
she's like crawling closer that looks
good huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
too he doesn't even know you don't even
know what it's like
it's like just i just want to eat it i
don't care
[ __ ] wait my finger
wow that's how much it took in these
ones we're gonna do it like this salt
bait
nice tahini bay i just got all over your
hair
my god ignore that ignore that yeah
ignore the actual fruit you know ignore
the fruit yeah i think by now it's
definitely more candy than fruit look at
this
[Music]
oh can i get one though i'm gonna get
one of those he covered his eyes
that was family friendly you want to
lick a finger it's pretty finger looking
good
but it's weird
[Laughter]
oh isaac you want to lick the plate oh
yes that's the good stuff
all right what is this you're licking
what is this what's going on over here i
mean
how does that taste sorry the best thing
it was the best thing ever
you're making my edges of my jaw lock
right now you ever get that feeling when
it's too sour and just like locks on you
yeah last step what's the best part the
final final final step here guys
hopefully i don't over pour it oh my
oh my gosh go crazy
this is the part where the street vendor
goes viral when i do this you know
oh wait there's not enough on this one
there we go
this is what we need for valentine's day
we're gonna talk yes
all right bro hey next year
the post that i saw they were promoting
it for like valentine's day really
all right guys we're ready
what is this you got a secret instagram
no
you should you should vlog you should be
yeah oh my gosh this has been the most
highly anticipated dessert of my life
all right everyone you all got your
forks this is the moment we've been
waiting for
my goodness i'm sorry look how bad this
looks guys
oh yeah all right who's going for what
who wants to be impolite go first
me i'll go for this one i'm calling my
name that beautiful one
oh my god look at all that there's like
a meatball
tell us tell us you guys dig it down
we're just watching you again the faster
you guys eat it the faster we can eat it
yeah go for it
i'm like cheers you don't have a camera
in your hand okay
all right i like i'm gonna take this one
because i like oh is this the big one
i like the wrap whoa you got the biggest
oh yeah the
well hardest sounds juicy better thick
the wrong channel hold on
wrong way
[Music]
let me do a study on this
what is going on we do an asmr video on
this because the way it
sounds as you're biting into it how
juicy and like also crunchy it is okay
i'm not waiting
we're not waiting any longer
it almost looks like you couldn't handle
the tangy it's
it's so strong it hits you all at once i
think that's why
i was twisting a little bit but your
eyes were twitching
oh you got the perfect bite dude
wow careful with the dripping that's
very sour the combination with
strawberry
and mango and chamoy and then
that he and then whatever that bit is
what is it uh
yeah oh my goodness oh my god this guy's
a perfect
food blogger what's going on he's
learned from the best wow
from this man right here he's enjoying
it
it's a soul dick allen thick whoa that's
a big bite
oh yeah
yeah you're talking about us this one
was
like really thick with the chamoy wrap
yeah
the fruit the fruit is good i changed
the whole flavor
two hours
[Applause]
okay so christina came out with a
beautiful idea of doing a mini chamango
which is a shot of it so we're going to
fill up
the these cups with the mango and then
top it off with that
the juices enzo i know you want one
okay good thing it's a gopro you just
spit out your food
are you okay what the heck he got scared
i think hasn't made him laugh
oh okay
[Music]
tequila
hey isaac you got that dad hold already
yeah
yay one arm
i was teaching him earlier are you
worried like you have them on the side
of your hip
nice
this is a sign of old age and like we're
not really down even though we want to
be down so we're all like
yeah let's drink that juice let's pass
some mangoes tequila shots maybe i don't
know
but then now we're all like no you know
i just chill out on the sauces where my
stuff is kind of hurting already oh
they're all taught two shots for
everyone oh
okay and i will give you 20 of these
isaac's like mom i want like five of
them yeah like i'm not old like you
[Music]
isaac there you go oh you're gonna take
the first shot
yeah you know what yellow means yolo
it means young opportunist loves
opportunities ah i like that that's
pretty good
that's pretty good that's exactly what
it means
yes mom what did you see him what you're
like
where'd you learn that from
mom i think tick tock might be a bad
influence she's she's proud that's a
proud face after
no i learned it here we go
cheers happy new year
[Applause]
that was a lot oh dude you
took the whole shot i love our songs
no it's more like a like you know when
you go to buffet and they give you like
a small amount of like gaspacho or
something
yeah just eat it what's wrong with you
guys that was an hors d'oeuvres
shot we just brought the uh og suv out
by taking shots
oh keep it classy
whoa he's young he can handle it
i don't even think it's gonna bother him
at all
i know when we did the one chip
challenge i feel like
i spent an eternity on the bath in the
bathroom and i think i feel like
five minutes maybe even less yeah and
you're over it already
[Music]
me